الخير رمضان كريم يترافق هذا الشهر الكريم
مع اشتداد الازمه الاقتصاديه في لبنان
التي بدات تنعكس لسنه الثالثه على التوالي
على كل المستويات المعيشيه والصحيه
والتربويه للمواطنين اللبنانيين لكن ذلك
لم يمنع من محاوله اعاده وضخ الحياه مجددا
للمدن والقرى اللبنانيه المختلفه
كمتشاهدون هذه مدينه صيدا في احد المعالم
الاثريه
يجري تجري بعض
النشاطات المرتبطه بالشهر الفضيل تحاول
الجمعيات من خلال ذلك التثبيت الهويه
والتقاليد والعادات التي تراجعت عن
السنوات السابقه ايضا الجمعيات الخيريه
تحاول من خلال هذا الشهر ضخ المال وجمع
التبرعات
للمواطنين الذين يحتاجونها خلال هذه
الفتره ولذلك فان الجمعيات الخيريه اعتبر
ان هذا الشهر الفضيل يعد نقطه اساسيه في
عملها لجمع ما يحتاج الناس في هذا الشهر
الفضيل مع اشتداد الازمه الاقتصاديه معي
الاستاذ فضل الله حسونه من تجمع الجمعيات
الاهليه في مدينه صيدا ماذا يشكل رمضان
بالنسبه اليكم نحن شهر رمضان بالنسبه
لالنا شهر مبارك
وبنبلش تحضيرات تقريبا قبل ثلاثه اشهر
لهذا الشهر الفضيل لانه الدوره الاقتصاديه
الحركه الاقتصاديه اللي بيعملها بتعود
بالخير والفائده على الاف الاف العيال
بمدينه صيدا ان كان القديمه وراء الخارجيه
مشان هيك تجمع المؤسسات الاهليه بهذا
الزلزال الاقتصاد اللي عم يمر على الشعب
اللبناني عملوا صناديق لشيء للامن الصحي
للاستشفيات للدواء للامن الاجتماعي للامن
التربوي لكل الحالات اللي عنا وما اكثرها
مش قادرين نجاوب على كل الحاجات اللي عم
تورد لعنا بس عم نحاول نعمل اضعف الايمان
وعاده عاده بشهر الخير كان يجي دعم
اقليمي عربي للبنان وللجمعيات السينما اجا
دعم فعم نحاول من اللحم الحي من المجتمع
المحلي من كل ما هو متوفر مدخرات موجوده
عند العيال والاسر والناس بالطبقه والوسطى
والطبقه الصغيره وكل شعبنا لنقدم قد ما
فينا نخدهم الناس على مستوى الحاجات التي
زادت مع الازمه الاقتصاديه كيف تسدون هذه
الثغره اليوم مع استداد الازمه ايضا على
الاشخاص الذين يقومون بفعل الخير عاده
يعني اكثر الشيعه من اعتمد على المغتربين
عم نعتمد على الناس اللي بعد عندهم
امكانات وماليه وبنفس الوقت الناس عم
بتتكافل مع بعضها وعم يتعود الشعب
اللبناني كيف يعيش بمصاري اقل تيدعم
العيال اللي بحاجه ميسي للدعم المالي نسبه
الفقر في لبنان فاقد الثمانين في المئه
لكن ذلك لم يمنع الجمعيات الاه والمؤسسات
المختلفه في المدن والقرى اللبنانيه من
اعاده ضخ الحياه
والعوده الى الجذور التي كانت سائده قبل
الازمه على سبيل المثال هذا معرض في مدينه
صيدا بجنوب لبنان هذه جمعيه تعنى بمرضى
داء الصرع تحاول بيع ما تيسر من انتاجها
لسد بعض الثغرات الماليه التي لديها ايضا
هناك حرفي لبناني الى جانبها يحاول عرض
منتجاته الفنيه وبيعها للحصول على نقود
ربما يحتاج الى تطوير حرفته ومهنته ويشمل
ايضا الامر عدد كبير من العارضين في هذه
المنطقه الجمعيات تريد من خلال هذا
المهرجان وهي التي نظمته التاكيد على ان
شهر رمضان هو شهر خير وتحاول ضخه الحياه
مجددا الى بعض الامور التي كانت تقوم بها
قبل الازمه اللبنانيه ما هي احمد عبد الله
من احمد اليوم ماذا تريدون من خلال هذا
المعرض وهذا المهرجان قوله نريد احياء
صراحه الاجواء الرمضانيه التقاليد
الرمضانيه يعني نحن هلا عاملين صوره من
رمضان بذكرنا بجذورنا وجدودنا اللي كانوا
يحكونا عنا لما نحنا كنا صغار حرفيين
ماكولات شعبيه
حلو شعبي اليوم بالنسبه للازمه الاقتصاديه
واعاده هذا النشاط مجددا في ظل هذه الازمه
هل تخاطرون بشيء هل تبغون امور اخرى
مرتبطه بهذه الازمه من خلال هذا المعرض
ربما في
السنوات المقبله نحن صراحه بنتحدى الازمه
الاقتصاديه بدعم الحرفيين يعني نحن كل
الحرفيين هون اكتر من 10,000 شخص على
السوق اللي احنا عاملينه لحتى ندعم هذه
الحرفيين سلط الضوء عليهم حرف تقاليد
صيداويه قديمه
بترجع لجذورنا ونحن صراحه
ودعمه لدعم القطاع التربوي بالمدينه عنا
استعدون للقطاع
الطلاب المحتاجين
ستساعدونا الطلاب المحتاجين نعم نحن هون
كل شيء عم نعمله يعني المصاري اللي عم
توصل لعنا هي حيروح هتروح دعم قطاع
التربوي بمدينه صيدا دعم الطلاب خصوصا
ماذا عن
الماكولات وبعض الامور المرتبطه بالانتاج
الشعبي يعني مثل ما نحن هلا شايفين هون
قدامنا في اكثر من 70 ستاند موجودين كلهم
من اكل من اكل وحرف وحلو
شعبوي تابع للمدينه نحن فيها هلا
شكرا احمد طبعا هذا جزء من الحياه التي
بدات تعود تدريجيا الى بعض المدن والخرا
والاحياء في لبنان في ظل هذا الشهر الكريم
هناك بعض المؤسسات وبعض الجمعيات تريد
تثبيت مبدا اساسي بان الازمه الاقتصاديه
لا يمكن باي شكل من الاشكال ان تؤثر على
روح رمضان والعادات والتقاليد التي رافقت
وتريد القول بان رمضان هو شهر ايضا
للعباده وللحياه ايضا
[موسيقى]